[موسيقى]
بلغ وزن هذا السلاح بين ثلاثه وسبعه كيلو
جرامات بحسب الاصدار
[موسيقى]
بعد خساره هتلر لقرابه نصف مليون من جنوده
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه اضطر الزعيم
النازي لتجنيد الاطفال وكبار السن
وبالتالي كانت الحاجه للسلاح خفيف يتناسب
مع قدراتهم البدنيه المحدوده
[موسيقى]
هذا السلاح الذي صممته القوات النازيه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه لعب دورا
فعالا في وقت متاخر من الحرب اعتبر مثلا
اول صاروخ مضاد للدروع يطلق يدويا
باستخدام قاذف لمره واحده فقط عرف بسهوله
استخدامه وقدرته على اختراق المدرعات بل
وتدميرها احيانا
[موسيقى]
ينسب للبنزر فاوست الفضل في تدمير المئات
من الدبابات السوفييتيه وعلى راسها ايضا
دبابه تي 34 وهو ما جعل البعض يلقبه بسلاح
الانتقام النازي
[موسيقى]